a rare sight in the dry winters of
Beijing the gate to the Forbidden City
covered in snow a few people have come
out to take in the spectacle but getting
inside is out of the question
just like almost all public facilities
Beijing's most famous historic site
remains closed the government took these
measures we support them we'd appreciate
even stricter measures business activity
has largely come to a halt across much
of the capital this is usually a
bustling commercial street lots of
souvenir shops snack shops tourists who
visit Beijing usually come to spend time
here today I am the only one everyday
human interaction has become suspicious
this shop asks its customers to stay
outside and communicate their needs from
the outside some pharmacies take the
same approach everyone is wearing it's a
national emergency we stand together
standing together should not be taken
literally residential complexes keep
strangers out in this compound visitors
have to register with their ID the
guards look for the place of birth who
Bay people can't get any Vanilli live
here
they'll be quarantined people from who
Bay province where the virus originated
are to be isolated in this hotel
discrimination against them is now
rampant at the entrance to the subway
system a mandatory temperature check
inside the same site as everywhere in
the city lots of space
trains are running as usual it's the
passengers were lacking this circle line
connects some of Beijing's most
important locations shopping areas the
railway station is usually quite crowded
but today you can see
Beijing has reported less than 300 cases
so far but fear here has spread much
faster than the virus ever could
matías bellanger who filed that report
joins us now from Beijing mattias given
that Beijing has not been severely
affected by the virus why are people
taking such extreme precautions I think
one reason is that people are afraid of
this virus because it's new and people
don't really know what it means another
reason is that authorities tell people
to take these measures people are
reminded constantly of the danger we we
know that only just less than 300 people
are registered as infected in the city
but given the long incubation period the
real number might of course be a little
higher and then the third reason is that
people here in Beijing remember very
well the outbreak of SARS a very similar
disease some 17 years ago where a
similar tactics avoiding contact was in
the end able to break the cycle of new
infections yes our people in China
satisfied with how their government is
dealing with this crisis these very
strict measures and these discriminatory
measures to separate who pay people from
other people for example are not met
with a lot of resistance
people as we have seen also some in this
report as support strict measures but
people are very unhappy on how far this
disease could progress and how late the
government has reacted and there is a
lot of discontent about how the
government has handled this crisis
especially in the beginnings tears thank
you very much for talking with us and
for your report that gives us such
interesting insights into what's going
on there reporter Mateus building a tear
in Beijing